Oi 6 It's gone soon
rai What's up
?
Eh,
it's fine to eat first,
but why is it so expensive when we can eat together as a family?As expected of my wife, that's
Subaru's breakfast.My mother did her best for Subaru today.
On your plate,
Midori no Mori-chan, mother, why am I the only one who piled up green
peas like this?
That day is a tire
No matter what day or time, it's a precious time that only comes once in a lifetime What do
you want?
I've been spinning this around since a while ago, but my
mother is trying to get a woman who doesn't like green
peas to overcome her likes and dislikes,
but don't feel it.  My sense of distrust grew more and more, but then
the husband takes responsibility for the wife
. Yeah, yeah, Subaru.
Hey, you were considerate, this green forest
That's right, everyone loves it
, it's nice to see [music] instead of pilaf
Subaru is good